-I'm so happy you're here.
I'm a big fans of both of you.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-Congrats.
"Ginny and Georgia,"
which, by the way,
I think I was the first person
to watch the show.
-Absolutely. I heard that.
-Of course. Yeah.
-Thank you. I was, right?
And I came in,
and everyone was like, "Oh, no.
We're all watching it.
Everyone is obsessed."
When Season 2 came out, it's the
number-1 show in 60 countries.
Number 1.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations on that.
Brianne, was there
a moment that you realized
that the show was taking off?
-Yeah. You know,
I was in Berlin over the summer.
A very, very delayed honeymoon.
And there happened to be
a marathon going by our hotel,
so my husband and I are
standing, watching the marathon.
And this very kind, grown man
runs out of the marathon
and approaches us and tells me
how much he enjoys the show.
And he says, "I know I'm not
your demographic,
but I love the show."
-He said, "I know
I'm not your demographic"?
-Yeah.
-That's funny
that he'd even say that.
How about you, Antonia?
When was the first time
you realized this show was big?
-Yeah, I was just in Paris
recently for Fashion Week,
and I was going up to my hotel,
and there was
a group of people just
waiting outside.
And I was like, "Oh, okay.
That's cool."
And this one fan --
she came up to me
and she was crying
and, like, shaking.
And I didn't speak French,
so I didn't know
how to properly comfort her.
So, I just -- I gave her a big
hug, and she gave me a letter.
And I went back to
my hotel room and I read it,
and it was one of
the most heartfelt things
I had read, I mean, just that
the show touched her so much.
-A global -- It's a global hit.
-Yeah.
-But I heard around the city,
you have new rules
for walking around.
-Yeah, because I live in
New York.
-Yeah.
-And...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, thank you. Thank you.
And I've learned not to
leave my apartment
at 3:00 p.m. on a weekday,
because then
the high schoolers -- that's
when they get out of school.
-That's your --
That is your demographic.
-Yeah, that is my demographic.
-You will be mobbed.
-And many of them are
bigger than me.
-I don't know, though.
Hey, it can be all times
of the day.
-They're scary.
-Yeah, you're right.
Now it's everybody.
-I love them, but they're scary.
-I'm loving it too, yeah.
Brianne, you went to school
here at NYU?
-I did, yeah.
-That's wild.
-I did.
-This is great.
-I love New York.
-You love New York.
-What do you love
about the city? Just...
-It's spontaneous.
Anything can happen here.
When I was a student at NYU,
I was a receptionist at
a hair salon, actually.
And I'm sitting there
at the front desk,
and Hugh Jackman
and his two young kids
go by on Razor scooters.
And I -- It, like, made my day.
But then, all of a sudden,
they circled back
in the direction
they were coming from,
and they come into the salon.
And he asked, "Can my daughter
use the restroom?"
And I think I just blacked out
and said, "Yes, absolutely."
So, one of the women takes
the daughter to the restroom,
and he and I are,
I think, making small talk.
I tell him about NYU
and what I'm studying.
And then, when his daughter
came back out,
he said,
"Thank Brianne and say hi
because she's gonna be
a famous actress one day."
-Come on. Hugh Jackman.
How great is that guy?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Class act.
-That's a class act.
-Yeah.
-How did you find out
about this role?
Did they come after you?
Did you audition for this?
How did you know about this?
-I was in the middle of
finals week at university.
I was trying to graduate.
-Wow.
-It was really difficult.
I barely did.
And I get it in my in-box,
the audition.
And I almost didn't
audition for it
because I thought I was going to
fail out of school.
But I read the script
and I really connected to
the character in a way that
I hadn't before for other roles.
And I knew that if I didn't
audition, I would regret it.
So I did.
And then like a couple weeks
after graduating,
I was flying back and forth
six different times to L.A.
to do chemistry reads.
-So many times. This poor girl.
-Too many times.
And, yeah,
I clearly do not regret it.
It was such a crazy timeline.
I was extremely lucky.
-Life-changing.
-Yeah.
And now you guys are -- Well,
you're "Ginny and Georgia" now.
So this is all
that's happening now.
-Yeah.
-"Ginny and Georgia."
-That's it. Congrats.
I think that's -- Now -- Yeah.
But why do you think
the show's resonated with
so many people
and different demographics?
-I think there's
really just something
for everyone in the show.
-Mm-hmm.
-You know, it's really,
like, hurried and fun,
but it's also very real.
We have such a diverse group
of characters
with different experiences.
-Story lines.
-Yeah.
And I think --
-It touches so many subjects.
-Yeah.
-And it's incredibly authentic.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-There's character for everyone
to really latch on to, so...
-How do we set it up for
anyone who hasn't seen
"Ginny and Georgia"?
-Ooh! Season 2, we pick up
right where we left off.
Only two weeks have passed.
Ginny, unfortunately,
finds out that her stepfather
did not die from natural causes
and that her mother
actually murdered him
on her behalf, so...
There's just that elephant
in the room.
-Yeah, that's -- Yeah.
-But Georgia
is busy planning a wedding,
so we're moving forward
and everything's fine.
-Yeah, there are
more important things
than to talk about murder.
-Much more important things.
-Than you being a murderer.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, of course.
-Yeah, it's minor.
-But you're a young, single mom.
I guess we can say that,
too, Georgia.
So you guys play, yeah,
mother, daughter
just before the murdering.
-Well, and after.
-If you haven't seen it,
I'm just setting that part up.
-It's not a spoiler.
-No, it's not a spoiler, yeah.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Brianne Howey
and Antonia Gentry in
"Ginny and Georgia."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Mom.
-Get out of here, Ginny.
-What are you doing?
-I called Don.
He told me about this book.
He doesn't deserve to be
a teacher.
-You don't think I know that?
What happens if you're caught?
You think they'll go easy on me?
You can't just go around doing
whatever you want all the time.
This is exactly why
I didn't tell you.
You have no idea what things
are like for me sometimes.
And I can't tell you anything,
because then you might go and do
something insane like this.
-I'm not going to sit back
and let someone
treat my daughter this way.
I'm your mother.
No one on this Earth
loves you more than I do.
-I know.
-I would do anything
for you, okay?
You know that.
-Yeah. Come on.
Brianne Howey, Antonia Gentry,
everyone!
Season 2 of "Ginny and Georgia"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back with a
performance from
Stephen Sanchez.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.